thor plusieurs personnalités et des
dizaines d'anonymes sont venus tenter
l'expérience vivre comme un sdf
reportage rome un post qui la nuit
dernière il a fait 4 degrés sur le canal
saint martin dans les 140 tente ceux qui
ont l'habitude de dormir dans un lit on
trouvait ça très pro frêche est courte
fruit une maigreur tente un quart temps
pour matelas le réveil est pénible
une vie de chien dans les instants
ce matin je pars effet autrement parce
que à force de dire qu'on pense que
c'est que de vivre sous la tente et pour
la gêner
basset
pour moi j'veux qu'on va pas lui dire
maintenant longtemps une telle forme
housse et spiro depuis samedi les
enfants de don quichotte invite tout le
monde à dormir aux côtés des sdf
même les deux dès cet après-midi le
comédien mouss diouf est venu en curieux
nous touche pas le sol pour faire d'eux
des cartons d'accord h 30 place du
mouvement les vivants ne sont pas
hostiles autrement c'est en même du 2 a
donné 8 e juste au-dessus rigoler 8
bourg-et-comin lui aussi les îles depuis
deux mois baissant abrite mais nexans
forte il a vu son pas d'autres ont
changé la vie et je crois que ça parce
que les gens sont comme vous et moi mais
je crois que le concept et dire non
dix nations ce 56e soit déjà que 15 qui
sont relogés fait déjà une victoire pour
nous aussi pour après les autres qu'ils
seront pas leur logeur protégera pas ce
soir l'opération pourrait s'étendre à 11
villes de nouveaux volontaires arrivent
et il leur faudra cette fois affronter
des températures en dessous de zéro